[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Marietta Slomka guten Abend wer
protestiert will natürlich gehört werden
im Prinzip gibt es dafür jetzt zwei
Varianten Protest der um Sympathie wirbt
und Protest der nrviert dass man mit
letzterem ziemlich viel Aufmerksamkeit
bekommen kann zeigt die letzte
Generation kaum etwas regt derzeit so
viele Leute so auf wie im Stau zu stehen
weil klimakleber in Aktion sind und
jeder redet darüber das ist auch genau
so gewollt allerdings wird nur noch
wenig darüber geredet was die Gruppe
inhaltlich fordert wie Tempo 100 auf
Autobahnen oder ein neuen euro-ticket da
gab es wahrlich schon wilderes in dieser
Republik
die Protestform ist dabei aber so
radikal dass der Staat nun äußerst
kraftvoll Auftritt heute sogar mit einer
bundesweiten Razzia mit der sonnewald
berichtet
es ist frühmorgens als Polizisten
bewaffnet und mit Schuss sicheren Westen
in mehreren Bundesländern anrücken um
Wohnungen und Geschäftsräume von
Mitgliedern der sogenannten letzten
Generation zu durchsuchen 15 Adressen
haben sie im Visier die
Generalstaatsanwaltschaft München hat
die Aktion angestoßen sie ermittelt
gegen sieben klimaaktivisten wegen der
Bildung einer kriminellen Vereinigung
den Beschuldigten wird konkret unter
anderem vorgeworfen eine Spendenaktion
organisiert beworben und durchgesetzt zu
haben um Geldern einzuwerten
um quasi weitere Straftaten der letzten
Generation zu finanzieren nach dem
bisherigen Erkenntnissen hat man auf
diese Weise 1,4 Millionen Euro gesammelt
seit rund einem Jahr kleben sich
klimaaktivisten der letzten Generation
bundesweit wie heute wieder auf dem
Berliner Ring an Autos oder auf
Straßenfest oder beschmieren Fassaden
mit Farbe wie gestern die Berliner
SPD-Zentrale um auf ihre Forderungen
aufmerksam zu machen im Fokus der
Ermittler stehen jetzt unter anderem
zwei Aktivisten die letztes Jahr
versucht haben sollen die Ölpipeline
Triest Ingolstadt zu sabotieren die
Bayern zentral versorgt legitimer
Protest endet immer dort wo Straftaten
begangen werden und andere in ihren
Rechten verletzt werden die
Staatsanwaltschaft hat heute auch
konnten der klimaaktivisten
beschlagnahmt und Vermögenswerte
gesichert
klar ist die letzte Generation begeht
immer wieder Straftaten die
entscheidende Frage ist aber hat sie
sich auch mit dem Ziel
zusammengeschlossen Straftaten zu Beginn
und sind die Straftaten die einzelnen
Mitglieder begehen erheblich genug denn
nur dann darf sie als kriminelle
Vereinigung verfolgt werden das ist aber
alles andere als geklärt und unter
Juristen äußerst umstritten nicht sie
sein kriminell so die Aktivisten der
letzten Generation kriminell sei die
fehlende politische Führung in der
Klimakrise die Bundesregierung fährt uns
gerade sehenden Auges in eine
klima-hülle sie drückt sogar aufs
Gaspedal mit ihren umstrittenen Aktionen
will die letzte Generation auf die
katastrophalen Folgen der Erderwärmung
aufmerksam machen die Bewegung sei zwar
provokant und konfrontativ nicht aber
als radikal zu bezeichnen so
protestforscher sie verzichte auf Gewalt
vor allem Gewalt gegen Personen und man
muss dazu sagen ihre Forderungen sind
wirklich nicht sehr radikal sondern
bewegen sich in einem doch eher
moderaten spekt rum wenn wir daran
denken dass es um Tempolimits und
bürgerräte hier gibt als zentrale
Forderung aus Protest gegen die heutigen
Razzien gegeneinandertag in Berlin
Unterstützer der letzten Generation auf
die Straße in den nächsten Tagen soll es
auch in Leipzig und München
Demonstrationen geben
die Klimaschützer von Fridays for future
dürften der Politik sympathischer sein
als die letzte Generation doch die
Frustration dürfte in beiden Bewegungen
gleich groß sein Olaf Scholz war als
klimakanzler angetreten die Grünen ganz
vorne mit dem Boot und sogar die FDP
hatte im Wahlkampf den Klimaschutz für
sich entdeckt die Hoffnungen die das
geweckt haben mag werden nun ziemliche
täuscht angesichts des
ampelkoalitionären Hickhacks die
behaarungskräfte sind stark und sie sind
es auch weil bei großen Teilen der
Bevölkerung die konkreten Kosten im
heute stärker wirken als die
abstrakteren Kosten im morgen im Zentrum
dieses Problems steht der
Bundeswirtschaftsminister Diana
Zimmermann berichtet
und täglich grüßt Robert Habeck der
Minister als Gast im
Wirtschaftsausschuss wieder einmal muss
er einen seiner Staatssekretäre
verteidigen diesmal geht es um Udo
Philipp der ehemalige Finanzmanager
erklärt der Opposition seine
finanziellen Beteiligungen an
Unternehmen und Fonds ein
Interessenkonflikt liegen nicht vor so
Robert Habeck die Regeln sind nicht nur
eingehalten worden die sind über erfüllt
worden Regeln Verschärfung das können
wir gerne diskutieren da hat das bmwk
überhaupt nichts dagegen wie der Udo
Philipp noch echt den persona wie schon
nach dem letzten Ausschuss Besuch geht
es danach in den Bundestag sichtlich
genervt Robert Habeck sein
heizungsgesetz im Zentrum der Kritik
die letzte beenden Sie diese Schauspiel
ziehen Sie den Gesetzentwurf zurück
gehen Sie zurück auf Los und fangen sie
im Sinne der Sache des Klimaschutzes
noch mal ganz von vorne die Grünen
wollen das Gesetz wie im Kabinett
verabredet noch vor der Sommerpause
durch den Bundestag bekommen doch die
FDP stellt sich quer ihre Ansicht des
über verboten nichts zu erreichen sei
stützt ausgerechnet der Leiter des
potsdam-instituts für
Klimafolgenforschung Otmar Edenhofer
meine Empfehlung an die Ampel wäre es
kurz durchzuatmen einen Schritt
zurückzutreten und einen neuen Anlauf
für die heizungswendezunehmen
Robert Habeck wollte ein nahbarer
Minister sein die Lust am Diskurs
scheint ihm im Moment vergangen
es zweifelnde war ja immer auch Teil
seiner Kommunikation und das war bisher
eigentlich überzeugend aber er traut
sich jetzt viele Dinge auch nicht er ist
ein Stück weit enttäuscht angeschlagen
auch angeschossen angezählt und das
macht sich natürlich auch in der
zurückhaltenderen und in einer
verunsicherten Kommunikation sichtbar
dabei wäre überzeugende Kommunikation
wichtiger denn je auf Rügen gehen die
Bürger gegen die vor ihrer Küste
geplanten
flüssiggasterminals auf die Barrikaden
nun melden auch Teile von habex grünen
unter ihnen die Umweltministerin
Bedenken an der Sinnhaftigkeit der
großen Energiereserven an alles
Rückschläger auf hawks-konto der
Minister hat Feder gemacht inzwischen
aber steht er für alles ungemachtes mit
der Energiewende verbunden wird Jungs
das Beispiel ein Gesetzentwurf sieht vor
dass die Kommunen Informationen über
Gebäude und ihre Heizungen sammeln so
soll der künftige Energiebedarf
ermittelt werden
von Gebäude Geheimdienst spricht die
Opposition von habex nächsten Hammer des
Boulevard der Gesetzentwurf stammt
allerdings nicht von Habeck sondern aus
dem Bauministerium
mit der Energiewende kommt jedenfalls
auch auf die Kommunen noch einiges zu an
Verwaltungsaufwand an Kosten davon haben
sie in den Städten und Gemeinden Eschen
eine Menge das bekam auch der Kanzler zu
hören als er heute die Hauptversammlung
des Deutschen Städtetags besuchte
Dominik Müller Rosell beginnt sein
Bericht in der Stadt Krefeld auch dort
klagt man über die Vielzahl zusätzlicher
Aufgaben die ihnen die Bundespolitik
auferwege
Krefeld am Niederrhein gezeichnet vom
Strukturwandel die Stadthalle bestes
Beispiel wie es um die Finanzen der
Stadt steht dieser Ort für Begegnung und
Kultur völlig kaputt gespart nie war
genug Geld da um die nötigen Reparaturen
anzugehen und wird ausgerechnet jetzt
das Geld für einen Abriss und Neubau
übrig sein wenn die Stadt verpflichtet
ist hunderte Millionen Euro mehr
auszugeben um neue Kitas zu bauen und
ganztagsschulplätze einzurichten
Flüchtlinge unterzubringen demnächst
ihre Gasheizungen umzurüsten und
zusätzlich ihren Mitarbeitern deutlich
mehr Geld zu zahlen nach neuem
Tarifabschluss also wie eine neue
Stadthalle bauen mit dem Rücken zur Wand
fragt sich Krefelds Obi Frank Meyer
kultur ist ein wichtiger Bestandteil
einer demokratischen Gesellschaft das
muss dann aber auch bezahlt werden und
im Moment ist es so dass auf die
Kommunen immer neue Aufgaben zu kommen
und wir nicht das Geld dafür bekommen um
diese zu erledigen das heißt also neue
Aufgaben fressen Alter Aufgaben oder wir
müssen sie schlechte erfüllen und das
kann nicht die Lösung sein Bund und Land
müssten sich finanziell beteiligen an
den Aufgaben die sie den Städten
aufbürden und dann sind da die
Altschulden eine halbe Milliarde Euro in
Krefeld auf die nun auch noch immer
höhere Zinsen fällig werden in einer
ähnlich Armen Kommune in Hagen sorgt
sich der Kämmerer um die Demokratie und
waren vor Populismus er spricht für ein
ganzes Bündnis hoch verschuldeter Städte
wenn Bund und Land die Verantwortung
dafür tragen dass wir in diese Situation
gekommen sind dann haben die Menschen
vor Ort auch in Anspruch darauf dass
Bund und Land uns helfen wenn das nicht
passiert für dies eben auch dazu ich sag
mal das Protagonisten auch in der
Politik
letztlich das Sagen bekommen die mit
scheinbar einfachen Lösungen versuchen
die Menschen zu überzeugen und ich finde
da müssten Bund und Land auch drüber
nachdenken dass das vermieden werden
sollte beim Deutschen Städtetag sagt der
Bundeskanzler heute erstmal keine
direkten Finanzhilfen zu die besonders
hoch verschuldeten Städte wolle er aber
unterstützen auch wenn das Zeit brauche
deshalb gehen wir auch das Problem der
kommunalen Altschulden an sie kennen
unsere Bereitschaft da eine Lösung zu
finden
gerade jetzt reden wir mit allen Seiten
wie wir die nötige Mehrheit für die
Änderung des Grundgesetzes erreichen
kann der Krefelder Obi hofft auf
zweierlei nach der Rede Geld und Tempo
für sich und seine Bürger wir brauchen
dringend mehr finanzielle Unterstützung
deswegen muss das was gerade
angesprochen wurde auch schnell
umgesetzt werden denn viel gibt es zu
tun in Krefeld für die Menschen die hier
leben
vor zehn Tagen wurde in Bremen gewählt
und jetzt zeichnet sich ab wie dort
künftig regiert verteilt da ist könnte
erneut eine rot-grün-rote Koalition
geben Bürgermeister bovenschulte von der
SPD teilte mit dass Koalitionsgespräche
mit grünen und Linke aufgenommen werden
sollen dafür habe sich der
SPD-Landesvorstand heute einstimmig
ausgesprochen es sei letztlich mehr
Schnittpunkte mit den Grünen und der
Linken als mit der CDU vorhanden gewesen
sagte
das Bundesverfassungsgericht berät über
die Grundsatzfrage ob gegen einen
mordverdächtigen nach einem Freispruch
das Strafverfahren wieder aufgenommen
werden kann wenn es eine neue Beweislage
gibt Anlass ist ein Mordfall der mehr
als 40 Jahre zurückliegt strittig ist
nun vor dem Verfassungsgericht ob der
Grundgesetz Artikel wonach niemand wegen
derselben Tat mehrmals bestraft werden
darf eine erneutes Verfahren ausschließt
oder ob es beim Mord doch möglich ist
wie eine neuere Regelung in der
Strafprozessordnung vorsieht die
Entscheidung wird in einigen Monaten
erwartet
der US-Republikaner ronde Säntis steigt
in das Rennen um die Kandidatur zur
US-Präsidentschaft ein dezentes
Gouverneur des Bundesstaates Florida
reichte die erforderlichen Unterlagen
bei der bundeswahlkommission ein neben
dem früheren Präsidenten Donald Trump
gilt der konservative Hardliner umfragen
zur Folge derzeit als aussichtsreichste
Anwärter der Republikaner
China werde Russland weiterhin bei
dessen kern-interessen nachdrücklich
unterstützen das versicherte
china-staats- und Parteichef hier bei
einem Treffen mit dem russischen
Ministerpräsidenten michusch dient in
Peking die staatliche Nachrichtenagentur
chinoa gegen nicht näher darauf ein was
mit kerninteressen gemeint ist wir
schussdienst Reise in die ist die
höchstrangigste Besuch aus Moskau seit
dem russischen Angriffskrieg gegen die
Ukraine china hat sich in dem Konflikt
grundsätzlich zu Vermittlung bereit
erklärt
derweil sorgte der Chef der berüchtigten
russischen wagnergruppe wieder für
Aufsehen jetzt warnte prigoshi davor das
sind Russland eine Revolution ausbrechen
könnte wenn weiterhin die Kinder
gewöhnlicher Russen in Sergen nach Hause
kehrten während die Kinder der Eliten
sich im Ausland sollten mit der
Zustandsbeschreibung Katja zweifellos
recht vergisst allerdings zu erwähnen
dass er selbst zigtausende Kinder
gewöhnlicher Russen in den sicheren Tod
schickt und daran mutmaßlich gut
verdient
Putin wiederum hantierte zuletzt im
russischen Fernsehen mit einer
französischen Landkarte aus dem 17
Jahrhundert um zu belegen dass die
Ukraine gar nicht existiert wobei er
geflissentlich übersah dass auf der
Karte das Wort Ukraine deutlich lesbar
steht das auch Russland auf dieser Karte
nicht als eigenständiger Staat
eingetragen ist und dass die Siedlung
die später St Petersburg wurde damals
noch zu Schweden gehört haben und für
diesen ganzen Irrsinn muss die Ukraine
weiter bluten wie mutig und erfinderisch
die Ukraine ihrem Angreifer widerstehen
hat unsere Porter Tim Krüger einmal mehr
in saporissia erlebt
mehr als ein Jahr lang konnte die
Zeitung Ruhm der Arbeit die ist schon
seit Sowjet Zeiten gibt wegen des
Krieges nicht erscheinen jetzt lässt
Journalistin Svetlana kapenko wieder
3000 Stück drucken aber in der Stadt
sapuricia nicht wie früher in ihrem
Heimatort der liegt zu nah an der Front
genau dort aber brauchen die Menschen
Informationen sagt sie
die Menschen möchten wissen was um sie
herum passiert und Sie brauchen
Informationen etwa darüber wo man sein
beschädigtes Haus registrieren lassen
kann oder wo es noch Ärzte gibt
Swetlana kapenko sieht aus wie eine
kriegsreporterin wenn Sie mit dem
Notdienst auf dem Weg in die teilweise
zerstörten Orte an der Front ist dabei
ist sie lokaljournalistin zusammen mit
anderen Hilfsgütern liefert sie ihre
Zeitung aus dann verteilen auf einmal
Raketen Lärm Svetlana bringt sich in
Sicherheit es ist immer eine emotionale
Rückkehr denn sie ist hier aufgewachsen
kennt viele Menschen
wenn ich darüber nachdenke kommen mir
die Tränen ich habe sie schon lange
nicht mehr gesehen seit über einem Jahr
es sind vor allem viele ältere Menschen
in den Orten an der Front geblieben aber
gerade sie haben oft kein Internet kein
Zugang zu Informationen
das wichtigste ist doch zu wissen was
passiert wir wissen gar nicht
[Musik]
es gibt kein Radio kein Fernsehen kein
Licht seit einem Jahr
so leben wir hier
die Menschen sind vom Raketen Terror
gezeichnet oft fließen Tränen viele
haben ihre Häuser verloren sie hoffen
auf die ukrainische gegen Offensive die
hier in der Gegend beginnen könnte
nachmittags wird es immer heftig
generell ist die Lage sehr angespannt
jeden Tag gibt es Beschuss Tag und Nacht
einen Ort weiter wurde das Haus von
Katharina Jacob getroffen die Raketen
haben ihre Fenster zerstört sie zeigt
uns die raketensplitter die durch die
Luft geflogen sind genau solche Splitter
haben auch schon ihren Enkel getötet
es ist beängstigend dieses Leben sehr
beängstigend ich habe sogar jedes mal
Angst wenn ich nach draußen auf Toilette
gehe vorgestern war es besonders schlimm
mein Gott es war schlimm
das alles trifft sehr stark deine Seele
die Seele wird verwundet und leidet so
geht es jedem
Svetlana capenco zeigt uns das alte
Redaktionsgebäude mit der Druckerei auch
hier sind die Fenster durch Raketen
Beschuss zerborsten aber Svetlana ist
sich sicher eines Tages werden sie hier
alles wieder aufbauen
der krieghund zuvor die Pandemie haben
unter anderem vor Augen geführt wie
fragil unsere globalen Lieferketten sind
und wie abhängig wie in vielen Bereichen
von China und anderen asiatischen
Produzenten sind etwa bei den Masken und
bei Medikamenten das ist aber nicht der
alleinige Grund dafür dass es seit
geraumer Zeit immer wieder
Lieferengpässe bei bestimmten
Medikamenten gibt etwa bei fiebersäften
für Kinder das Problem ist in
erheblichen Maße ausgemacht weil gespart
werden sollte mit ungewollten
Nebenwirkungen wie der
Bundesgesundheitsminister nun
gegensteuern will berichtet Britta
Spiekermann
Familie Stein wartet in einer Erfurter
Kinderarztpraxis auch Behandlung
Scharlach geht um und Penicillin ist mal
wieder Mangelware
wir leben halt in Deutschland wo es ja
doch Industrieland ist und dann passiert
sowas wo man halt ich kenne es auch
unbekanntenkreis man rennt die
Medikamenten hinterher quasi man rennt
von der Apotheke zur Apotheke dass man
irgendetwas bekommt für die Kinder der
Notstand als Dejavue Liefering Pässe
Versorgungsmangel gehören zum Alltag mit
schlechter Prognose wir wünschen und
hoffen dass es hier eine Änderung geben
wird damit war wirklich nicht im Oktober
die Praxen zu machen müssen weil wir
sagen können wir wir können mit den
Eltern nicht mehr kommunizieren wir
können die Diagnose stellen aber wir
können keine Behandlung einleiten
aktuell gibt es bei 490 Arzneimitteln
liefer in Pässe nun endlich heute der
gefährliche medikamentenmangel im
Bundestag man habe es mit der
Ökonomisierung übertrieben sagt
Lauterbach auch das ein Dejavue der
Minister konzentriert sich in seiner
Rede auf eine Absicht
Kollegen wir müssen einen Teil der
Produktion wieder nach Europa
zurückholen es wird langfristig nicht
möglich sein bei wichtigen Generika
allein auf Lieferungen aus Asien oder
aus anderen Ländern also angewiesen zu
sein die CDU immerhin früherer
Koalitionspartner und mitverantwortlich
für die Misere fragt scheinbar
überrascht warum denn erst jetzt jetzt
im Mai 2023 jetzt also soll ein
Frühwarnsystem kommen bei Engpässen
jetzt sollen Vorräte angelegt werden bei
kinderarzneimitteln sollen die
Preisregeln nachhaltig gelockert werden
und die inländische Produktion soll
angekurbelt werden viel zu spät sagen
Experten deren warnende rufe über Jahre
Verhalten man hat bei gerade bei
Generika versucht die so billig für die
Krankenkassen das darstellbar zu machen
wie es nur geht und über die Jahre hat
man über Rabattverträge Festbeträge
Preismoratorium alles dran getan dort
Geld zu sparen und das Recht sich jetzt
ganz fürchterlich die Produktion ist vor
Jahren abgewandert 70 bis 80 Prozent der
Wirkstoffe kommen aus China und Indien
es gibt störanfällige Lieferwege
geopolitische krisen können zur massiven
Ausfällen führen hierzulande werden kaum
noch Arzneimittel produziert die
Pharmaindustrie kalkuliert
kühlt der Politik zu definieren bei
welchen Arzneimitteln wollen wir Europa
Stärken in der Produktion wie wollen wir
weniger abhängig sein in der Versorgung
und dann muss man über die richtigen
Wege reden das hat was mit Preisen zu
tun aber es hat auch damit was zu tun
dass man womöglich Produktionsstätten
unterstützen wird müssen die Produktion
in Deutschland wieder aufzubauen dauert
für einzelne Medikamente fünf Jahre und
ist kostspielig das scheint der Preis zu
sein für ein Stück Unabhängigkeit
und jetzt geht es bei dir noch mal
weiter Heinz mit einem Jubiläum die
Europäische Zentralbank mit 25 am 1 Juni
1998 nahm die EZB ihrer Arbeit auf zu
diesem Anlass heute Abend ein Festakt in
Frankfurt am Main Valeria Halle in
welcher Stimmung beginnt die EZB dieses
Jubiläum na ich vermute mal mit einer
Portion Stolz die EZB ist ja nun mal
eine der wichtigsten Notenbanken der
Welt und die bislang vier Chefs haben
sie ja auch durch teils schwieriges
Fahrwasser geführt aus der Finanzkrise
2007 wurden Lehren gezogen was der EZB
auch eine neue Aufgabe einbrachte
seither überwacht die EZB die größten
Banken im Euroraum direkt Festakt in
Frankfurt mit allerlei polits ihren
Platz in der Geschichte haben sie längst
gefunden Christine Lagarde Seite an
Seite mit ihren Vorgängern trische und
Draghi deren Amtszeiten schon von Finanz
und Schuldenkrisen geprägt waren auch
bekämpft für die Stabilität des Euros
den man sich 2002 zum ersten Mal am
Automaten ziehen konnte heute gilt der
Euro in 20 EU-Staaten wichtigste Aufgabe
der EZB sind stabile Preise insofern
fällt das Jubiläum auf eine etwas
ungünstige Zeit noch nie war die
Inflation so hoch noch nie musste die
EZB die Zinsen in so kurzer Zeit so
stark anheben vom Idealwert 2% Teuerung
ist die immer noch meilenweit entfernt
die europäische Notenbank muss sich
deshalb auch viel Kritik anhören vor
allem eine dass sie zum Kreditgeber
letzter Instanz geworden ist eine auf
die sich die Politik verlassen auf der
sie sich sogar ein Stück weit ausruhen
kann
vielen Dank
Musik Superstar Tina Turner ist
gestorben im Alter von 83 Jahren in der
Schweiz hier am Abend bekannt gegeben
wurde an Stationen ihrer Karriere
erinnert kein Felix
Tina Turner Legende schon zu Lebzeiten
eine beispiellose Power Stimme die
tatsächlich nur durch einen Zufall
Bekanntheit erlangte
als für eine Plattenaufnahme in der Band
ihres späteren Ehemanns Ike Turner die
Leadsängerin ausfällt springt Tina
Turner ein befohlen love 1960 sofort in
den Hitparaden
Eick und Tina treten sogar als Vorgruppe
der Rolling Stones auf doch was
verheißungsvoll beginnt endet im Chaos
Tina Turner sagt später ein Tyrann sie
verlässt die 1976 startet solo durch
schreibt unzählige Hits
das ist einer von ihnen
James Bond Goldeneye 1995
[Musik]
doch auch vor großen Erfolg macht
Rassismus nicht halt Tina Turner wurde
ihr Leben lang damit konfrontiert das
hat sie geprägt
[Musik]
daher kommt meine Disziplin ich musste
lernen mit Vorurteilen umzugehen deshalb
ist meine Einstellung zum Leben von
eiserner Selbstdisziplin geprägt
und diese Selbstdisziplin hat Tina
Turner in ihrem schillernden Leben sehr
sehr weit gebracht
[Musik]
und um kurz nach 1 Uhr nach dem
heute-update sendet das ZDF die
Dokumentation Tina Turner Rock Queen
Mutter Kämpferin
und jetzt die Zahlen vom Lotto am
Mittwoch sie lauten wie immer ohne
Gewähr 1 6 7 9 16 43 Superzahl 5 und
weitere Gewinnzahlen finden sie auf
lotto.zdf.de und im ZDF Text auf Seite
das Fußball ein Geschäft ist Vereine
Unternehmen das ist ja wahrlich keine
neue Erkenntnis für Romantik ist da
nicht allzu viel Raum wenn man
international mithalten will was der
Bundesliga zunehmend schwer fällt die
deutsche Fußballliga wollte deshalb über
einen Investor frisches Kapital anzapfen
und zwei Milliarden sollten so in die
Kasse kommen einem Strippen ist Vorhaben
aus dem vorerst auch nichts wird auf der
mit Spannung erwarteten
Mitgliederversammlung heute gab es dafür
nicht die erforderliche Mehrheit martin
Wolf berichtet
Bayerns Vorstandsvorsitzender Oliver
Kahn in Weltuntergangsstimmung dass das
dfl-geschäft mit einem Investor nicht
zustande kommt wird seiner Meinung nach
Niederlagen wie diese zur Norm machen
unterlegene deutsche Top-Clubs die nicht
mehr mithalten können mit den
Superreichen englischen Premier League
Clubs nicht nur Kahn befürchte dass nun
was das an Konsequenzen nach sich zieht
in den nächsten Jahren dass es schwer
abschätzbar aber ich glaube dass wir
insgesamt als Liga keinen leichten
Zeiten entgegen gehen die Befürworter
eines Investoren Einstiegs dürften heute
morgen noch auf eine zwei Drittel
Mehrheit hoffen das heißt auf 24 Stimmen
aus erster und zweiter Liga der
Milliarden die mit einer
Beteiligungsgesellschaft davor dass der
Investor 2 Milliarden Euro bereitstellt
diese sollten dann vor allem die
medienvermarktung im Ausland
vorantreiben dafür hätte der Investor 20
Jahre lang 12,5% der Einnahmen kassiert
bei der Zeit 1,3 Milliarden Euro
Einnahmen pro Saison
ämen in 20 Jahren 26 Milliarden zusammen
und damit für den Investor 3,25
Milliarden
gegen dieses Modell liefen zuletzt vor
allem die organisierten Fans etlicher
Bundesligisten Sturm der Profifußball
entfernen sich damit noch weiter von dem
Weg was Fußball für sie ausmacht
mehr vermarktungsanlöse gibt es in
erster Linie mit Maßnahmen wir Fans sehr
sehr kritisch ziehen da gibt es sehr
viele Sorgen Richtung Spieltag
Zerstückelung dazu kommt leider noch
dass die gelders Investors ja sehr sehr
ungleich verteilt werden sollen die die
schon viel haben bekommen viel die
kleinen bekommen möglichst wenig des
zementiert aktuelle Verhältnisse und
verhinderten fernwettbewerb zumal die
drei in Frage kommenden Investoren als
Private Equity Unternehmen einzig und
allein an Gewinnerzielung interessiert
sein
öffentlich hatten sich mit dem ersten fC
Köln dem FC Augsburg und Zweitligist St
Pauli nur drei Vereine gegen den Plan
ausgesprochen bei der heutigen geheimen
Abstimmung waren es dann 11 und 5
Enthaltung 20 Jahre Stimmen reicht nicht
zur zwei Drittel Mehrheit ist für uns
klar dass der Prozess mit dem heutigen
Tage dann zu Ende ist manchmal ist das
Leben noch einfach
der hat gelassen reagiert nicht alle
diejenigen die dagegen waren und das
auch sehr lautstark formuliert haben die
werden natürlich eine Frage beantworten
müssen wo kommt in Zukunft Sicherheit
und Stabilität für die Bundesliga her
die Fans dürften heute aber erst mal das
Nein zum Investoren Einstieg feiern
das war es von uns gleich geht es im
auslandsjournal weiter unter anderem mit
einem Blick in die Türkei kurz vor der
Stichwahl und um 0 Uhr gibt es dann
unsere heute schon ein Update mit
Christopher Wehrmann bis morgen auf
Wiedersehen
[Musik]
schon guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter auf dem Atlantik
haben wir es mit einem großen tief zu
tun dass sich langsam ausdehnt und das
Wetter beruhigt aber auf seiner Ostseite
schmuggelt sich diese Kaltfront nach
Deutschland und sorgt für einige Wolken
ansonsten ist noch dieses Tief hier am
Mittelmeer aktiv es wandert Richtung
Spanien bringt dort Regen und morgen im
Tagesverlauf tatsächlich auch an den
Alpen einige Schauer in Deutschland
schauen wir uns das genauer an in der
Nacht gibt es regen der wird allmählich
Nachlassen von Norden her driften neue
Wolken rein ansonsten bildet sich Nebel
bei tiefsten Temperaturen von 3 Grad im
Vogtland und im hessischen Bergland z.B
und 10 Grad Richtung Nordsee das ist die
Temperatur Spanne morgen ist es dann im
Süden erst einmal trocken aber im
Tagesverlauf bilden sich hier einzelne
Schauer ansonsten driften von Nordwesten
Wolken ins Land zuzuhören zur Kaltfront
ansonsten im Süden viel Sonnenschein und
hinter der Kaltfront ebenfalls viel
Sonne Temperaturen erreichen höchste
Werte von 24 Grad im Südosten 23 im
Rhein-Main-Gebiet und nur 13 Grad an der
Nordsee die nächsten Tage bleiben
überwiegend freundlich mit viel
Sonnenschein Freitag Richtung Norden
relativ kühl hier um die 14 Grad sonst
24 und am Wochenende wird es allmählich
wärmer am Sonntag bis 27 Grad und damit
ein schöner Abend